Віталія - дружина пораненого військовослужбовця. Її чоловік отримав мінно-вибухове поранення
під Бахмутом ще всередині літа. Осколок від міни перебив артерію на нозі,
і кінцівку довелося ампутувати. Під час лікування чоловіка жінка почала займатися
оформленням документів і потрапила у справжнє бюрократичне пекло.
Я була заплутана до такої взагалі межі, що просто хотілося не один раз, хотілося щовечора
просто закинути всі ці документи, сісти, плакати і спалити їх. Тому що це дуже, дуже заплутана штука.
І коли ти чогось добиваєшся, якусь довідку, а вона виявляється неправильна,
тобто хтось їй просто не дуже зручно, там якось щось сидів наклацав на клавіатурі,
поробив такі помилки, які він, людина, яка, наприклад, видала цю довідку з помилками,
вона називає цю довідку типу опечатка. А в іншому кабінеті це вже називають
страшенною помилкою. І цей документ є вже недійсним.
Найважливіший документ, який треба роздобути військовому після поранення,
- це довідка про обставини травми. У ній має бути вказано, що травма отримана
під час захисту батьківщини. Саме її, за словами Віталії, найчастіше видають із помилками.
Щоб отримати таку довідку, жінка витратила два з половиною місяці.
А щоб отримати безкоштовне протезування, треба було пройти ще військово-лікарську комісію,
яка мала видати довідку зі словами "потребує протезування".
Ми попросили у ВЛК, що надайте нам таку довідку. Вони сказали: добре, ми вам завтра її привеземо.
Окей, ну, привозять довідку, типу, потребує відпустки. Ми такі, ні, ні, ні, ви не зрозуміли,
нам потрібна довідка "потребує протезування". Ми так підраховували, що їх було у нас 7 цих довідок
про потребу у відпустці. Ми поїхали до центрального шпиталю, я заїхала в госпіталь,
взяла чоловіка. Я приїжджаю в центральний госпіталь, а там пройтися треба добряче
на одній нозі туди, куди до ВЛК треба потрапити. І ми говоримо: дивіться, нема (ноги),
нам не треба відпустка, нам потрібно протезування!
Так само зробили помилку і під час розширеного ВЛК, каже Віталія, - у пункті, від якого
залежать виплати за поранення і забезпечення протезування.
А під час проходження медико-соціальної експертної комісії подружжя зіштовхнулося
ще й з поганим ставленням медперсоналу.
Таких історій, як у Віталії та її чоловіка, в Україні сотні, якщо не тисячі.
Своїм досвідом з нами поділився адвокат і військовий Масі Найєм.
Ви знаєте, настільки це було важко, що я навіть досі не знаю цього шляху.
Тільки завдяки тому, що ми займаємося правовим навігатором в громадській організації "Принцип",
я вивчив, почитав, мені це цікаво. Але я його не пройду сам самостійно,
якщо я його буду проходити. Тільки у винятковому випадку, коли мені не буде, що їсти,
мені не буде, де жити, і держава дасть якісь копійки як подаяння: на, візьми там 500 тисяч гривень.
Мені, вибачте, щоб я знав, що моє око коштує 500 тисяч гривень, я заплатив би мільйон,
щоб у мене залишилося два.
Після поранення Масі мав пройти військово-лікарську комісію, щоб отримати документ,
чому він не перебуває у військовій частині.
Я пішов на військову лікарську комісію і був шокований. Я бачив купу людей,
які стоять у військовій формі, поранені. І мені на секундочку здавалося, що, знаєте, мабуть,
це якесь там відділення, не знаю, яке виписує людей, щоб вони швидше поїхали за кордон.
Але якщо ви так ставитеся до людей, які віддали частину свого здоров'я, це негарно.
Масі був 72-им у черзі, а довідку видавали лише з 13 до 15 години дня.
І я психанув, поїхав додому. Наступного дня приїхав раніше, зайняв чергу, отримав цей документ
і поїхав у військову частину. Робив це достатньо весело, тому що в мене є машина, є водій,
який мене возить. Окей, клас. Але я просто уявляю тепер те саме хлопцю, у якого немає ноги.
Він просто їде з Борщагівки, сідає на трамвай, їде до метро, на метро доїжджає до Печерська,
там іде пішки до військово-лікарської комісії, займає чергу, не проходить, мабуть, її,
і повертається назад додому. І повторює це так два чи три рази.
У нього в серці залишається величезна дірка від такого ставлення держави до нього.
Щоб захистити права поранених військовослужбовців, Масі Найєм і правозахисниця Любов Галан
створили громадську організацію "Принцип".  Вони почали опрацьовувати шлях,
яким проходять поранені, спілкуватися з органами влади і проробляти зрозумілі інструкції:
що і як мають робити військові після поранення.
Ми запустили наш перший продукт. Це буде правовий навігатор для поранених військовослужбовців.
Безкоштовно можна там завантажити всі документи, які необхідно, наприклад, заповнити,
якщо боєць хоче якийсь рапорт подати чи скаргу. А також побачити, як мають виглядати ті документи,
які він має отримати від релевантних органів влади, своєї військової частини чи закладу охорони здоров'я,
де він чи вона перебуває, для того, щоби бути таким більш самозарадним при контакті з ними.
Але не завжди у правовому полі все працює так, як належить. Наприклад, не встановлені строки,
в які має бути виданий висновок ВЛК, або затягують видачу довідки про обставини травми.
А це впливає і на отримання грошової допомоги, і на можливість оформити інвалідність
чи отримати доступ до додаткових засобів реабілітації.
Тому в правозахисному центрі для військовослужбовців прагнуть подолати проблему системно.
Для цього працюють із МОЗ, мінцифри та міноборони. Так у січні мінцифри вже анонсували
цифровізацію військово-лікарської комісії.
Перше - це цифровізація процесів, пов'язаних з ВЛК, а саме створення можливості доступу
до медично-інформаційної системи військових закладів охорони здоров'я.
Якщо сказати простими словами, то зараз ті медично-інформаційні системи,
до яких ми звикли в цивільних закладах охорони здоров'я, які дозволяють нам записуватися онлайн,
сімейному лікарю дивитися якісь документи чи висновки дистанційно,
недоступні для військових закладів охорони здоров'я. Це мають виправити.
Друге - планують створити електронний документообіг, щоб скоротити черги
і не змушувати військового кілька разів збирати їх по всій країні.
Наша задача - якомога зменшити кількість переадресацій цього військовослужбовця
і обов'язку для нього особисто заносити кудись документи і якісь документи забирати.
Це не тільки технічне питання, як це запустити, це ще й питання змін правових рамок
для того, щоб прибрати ті запобіжники, які забороняють йому це робити якимось чином дистанційно.
Крім того, хочуть забезпечити поранених належним сервісним обслуговуванням.
Цим вже почали займатися волонтери на місцях. Так, наприклад, після скандалу у Львові
волонтери почали допомагати військовим на території гарнізонної поліклініки,
де проходить військово-лікарська комісія.
У самій поліклініці ми побачили стан будівлі, морального стану всередині в колективі,
який працював з нашими пораненими за зразком такого сервісу, який був усередині 80-х років,
тобто байдужість до людей, які звертаються до тебе за тими потребами,
які є для твоєї установи спеціальними.
Справді існували неймовірні черги. Ці черги виглядали так, що вони були потрійні.
Спочатку хлопці і дівчата, яким треба було потрапити до фахівців спеціалізованих, лікарів вузькопрофільних,
вони організовували чергу, щоб потрапити в саму поліклініку, тоді черга для того,
щоб потрапити в реєстратуру, і звідти вони вже отримували письмові талончики
на маленьких клаптиках паперу, коли і в які кабінети вони можуть прийти.
Ці клаптики не гарантували, що ти будеш відвідувати свого лікаря в той час,
тому що лікар міг бути відсутній з об'єктивних чи суб'єктивних причин.
І відповідно це пекло тривало тижнями.
Та головне, каже Тетяна, у персоналу була відсутня емпатія до поранених бійців.
Їм ніхто не допомагав, ліфт не працював через перебої зі світлом, стан вбиральні був жахливим,
а у чергах - по пів тисячі поранених.
Тому волонтери пробилися у медзаклад і почали вимагати змін.
Домоглися зміни керівництва та реконструкції поліклініки, забезпечили військових водою,
гарячими напоями, смаколиками, встановили інформаційні стенди з номерами
безкоштовної психологічної та юридичної допомоги,
організували пункти вимірювання тиску та забезпечили санітарні зони.
Комфорт є в тому, що третій поверх, який є вхідним поверхом, цокольний,
він є тепер безбар'єрним. Двері, які автоматично відкриваються, не спричиняють незручності
для тих, хто на візочку чи на милицях. Те, що було раніше, - двері, які лабіринтами йшли.
І відразу на вході є велика санітарна зона, в тому числі інклюзивна, вона є на вході,
там, де вона б мала бути. Відразу навпроти ліфт, який тепер працює, його відреконструювали,
оновили і поставили на нього окремий генератор, навіть не пов'язаний так з відключенням світла,
як просто щоб ліфт був заструмлений, щоб не виникало проблем.
Крім того, після численних скарг і звернень у МОЗ готуються до реформи системи
проведення медико-соціальної експертизи, яка встановлює інвалідність.
Планують створити мультидисциплінарні реабілітаційні команди у лікарнях,
а саму систему перевести в електронний формат, щоб зменшити корупцію.
Та поки усі ці зміни і реформи впровадять, поранені військові залишаються сам на сам
зі своїми проблемами.
У нас зараз золотий час для змін, які можуть статися для військових у системі
надання цих послуг. Тобто, єдине, чого хочеться від цивільних людей і від держави
у ставленні до військових, - це поваги. Поваги, коли надають ці послуги.
Я бачу по політичній волі людей, що це можливо.
Головне, щоб на це вистачило ресурсу і уваги суспільства.